d'abord eu une explosion puis de la
fumée le 4 mars dernier la centrale
nucléaire de zappos rôji est en proie
aux flammes après avoir été bombardé par
l'armée russe lincendie qui a été éteint
n'a touché qu'un bâtiment administratif
situé à 500 mètres des réacteurs un
incendie est un à temps
mais les russes sont désormais pris le
contrôle de ce site stratégique
la centrale la plus puissante d'europe
qui fournit un cinquième de
l'électricité en ukraine l'objectif est
clair affaiblir le pays est tout
simplement possible de déteindre une
centrale nucléaire on est on peut la
mettre au repos on peut donc dans ces
cas là effectivement couper
l'électricité sans électricité il est
très difficile de faire marcher tout
simplement une fois que les groupes
électrogènes seront épuisés et bien tout
simplement les hôpitaux les postes de
commandement les chaînes télé et cela
rendra la situation sur le terrain est
beaucoup plus critique zappos rôji
dispose de six réacteurs nucléaires sur
les quinze que compte l'ukraine mais il
ya aussi des réacteurs à l'arrêt comme à
tchernobyl un site passé lui aussi sous
contrôle russe après plusieurs
interruptions ces derniers jours
l'alimentation électrique de la centrale
a été rétablie ce mardi une alimentation
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité des
assemblages combustibles stockés sur
place
le président ukrainien accuse moscou
d'agiter la terreur nucléaire mais si la
russie n'a aucun intérêt à provoquer une
catastrophe dont elle subéraies aussi
les conséquences ces actions sont jugées
extrêmement dangereuse
lorsque vous avez des centrales
nucléaires active cela pourrait mener au
désastre tout ce qu'il faut c'est un
missile qui explosent ou commandes voix
des bombardements qui provoque un
incendie s'il incendie n'avait pas été
maîtrisé dans cette centrale électrique
il aurait pu se déplacer dans la zone du
réacteur il nous aurions pu assister à
une fusion nucléaire
près de 50% de l'électricité en ukraine
est produite grâce à ses centrales
nucléaires la russie risque donc de
continuer à tenter de prendre le
contrôle de ces infrastructures
énergétiques essentiels pour le pays